what if Superman grabbed the president
right out of the Oval Office who would
have stopped him I want to build a team
with some very bad people who I think
can do some good
y'all Joker's must be crazy disobey me
you die
irritate or vex me I'm known to be quite
vexing I'm just full warning you you die
don't forget we're the bad guys all of
that chit chats gonna get charged I
wonder who I want to see stop I was
trying to get you there
no I feelings alright we good
what you having beer whiskey what am i
12 how about you have stuff water that's
a good idea
hey youtubers is Charlie it's almost
comic-con we got some new Suicide Squad
footage and we've got some clarification
on what's going on with the Joker Harley
Quinn and Batman and Suicide Squad so
here's the breakdown so important stuff
first story points what the hell is the
Joker doing in this movie and what is
Batman's involvement so the Joker has
this laser-like plan to reunite with
Harley Quinn she's been in prison 1 and
2 slightly less likely even though she's
still obsessed with him like Margot
Robbie was very clear that her Harley
Quinn is completely obsessed with the
Joker despite all the terrible things
that he does so they had this really
dysfunctional loving relationship but as
much as we're gonna see her origin story
in the movie like she's already Harley
Quinn when the movie picks up but you
learned some serious [ __ ] has gone down
death in the family style so it sounds
like Harley Quinn was a part of that
that also caused some estrangement from
the Joker despite the fact that they
still care about each other the Joker of
course being very toxic in his desire
for Harley Quinn like it's really
interesting to see the spin that they
put on their relationship because there
have been so many different versions of
it in the comics like in the animated
series the Joker is a little bit nicer
to Harley Quinn in the more recent
comics the Joker's more abusive so we'll
see what kind of spin they put on that
in this movie but Harley Quinn is part
of the Suicide Squad they have their
mission the Joker is kind of like off
tangential to that trying to reunite
with Harley Quinn so he has this crazy
plan so he's kind of like this external
force that doesn't necessarily make him
the biggest villain of the film the
actual target of their mission sounds
like it's going to be tattoo man because
they call it a mystical threat like
their main target in Midway city that's
actually where most of the film's gonna
take place in Midway city is a mystical
threat so that's probably the tattoo man
he can use the tattoos on his body to
create physical objects so projectiles
any pretty much anything you could
imagine
so Amanda Waller in the wake of what
happened during Batman V Superman in the
Kryptonians attack is like we need a
defense against this and even though the
government is like okay you know we're
not super cool with you putting together
a team of super villains
she does it anyway it becomes Task Force
X the first person that she recruits is
going to be in chant rest' and just like
we get to see Harley Quinn's origin
story in this we'll get to see
Enchantress's origin story - she's an
archaeologist that gets possessed by an
ancient witch so they put together tests
for sex but what the hell is Batman
doing in this film well one I know a lot
of people are like what's on his face
here that's just a breathing apparatus
he's diving into the water so that's
just so he can breathe underwater now
you know nothing special about that but
the really cool thing if you've ever
watched any of the Suicide Squad
animated movies or you've read the
comics you know that Amanda Waller puts
collars on them that will explode label
basically explode their heads like
watermelons if they do something that
she doesn't like or if they try to
escape or they go off mission so the
first real connection to Batman in this
film is that the collars are actually
made by Wayne tech which I know sounds
weird you know Batman would create a
collar for prisoners that would make
their heads blow up but you have to
remember that Ben Affleck's Batman is
willing to kill people and part of his
art during Batman V Superman is being
inspired by what Superman does and that
he is not so willing to kill people
so the collar tech comes from Batman but
then you have the Joker here and
obviously this is a connected universe
so once the Joker surfaces makes a
beeline for Harley Quinn while they're
on their mission that's also probably
where actual like physical Batman enters
the story one of the fun things about
Suicide Squad though is that Batman
dislikes Amanda Waller just as much as
he dislikes other super villains because
she's kind of a super villain in her own
right she's just like a wolf in sheep's
clothing who has access to the White
House so Viola Davis is gonna be
fantastic in this film but most of my
attention now it's gonna be on the Joker
trying to reunite with Harley Quinn and
just completely derail the suicide
squads mission just absolutely does not
care about that there's like okay Harley
pack your things time to come home to
our strip club the Comic Con what's
going on with the DC movies at Comic Con
there is a Warner Brothers panel they
book like a mystery two-hour block just
like they do every year and then they'll
bring a couple surprises but the biggest
films that they're gonna be hyping or
Wonder Woman and Suicide Squad but I
would expect most of the new stuff that
you have not seen to come from Wonder
Woman they might sneak in some Justice
League surprises to that panel is gonna
be Saturday morning and of course I'm
gonna be doing a whole bunch of Comic
Con videos when we get a little bit
closer I'll do some preview videos so be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
actually I'll go ahead start a new round
of the giveaway now there'll be a whole
bunch of Comic Con giveaways going on
too so all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post a DC video so let me
know in the
what kind of DC movie steps do you want
to see a comic-con I feel like everybody
wants to see Justice League footage I'm
not expecting any but they might bring a
small teaser later tonight I'll be
posting my Doctor Strange pre lewd video
there's a pre lewd comic that explains
what's going on with the characters
especially Mass Mikkelsen as well as the
Wang character so I'll explain all that
when I post Doctor Strange later tonight
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my
spider-man homecoming behind the scenes
video and you can click here for my Thor
Ragnarok behind the scenes video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight